Hello. I'm the Nostalgia Critic, I remember it so you don't have to. Well seeing how we are at the end of Nickelodeon Month.
I can safely say that I am not the least bit happy.
Why?
Because I have to review what many consider to be a double order of
bullshit with extra crap and a side order of dick cheese
The fast-food abomination simply known as Good Burger
Based off the hit sketch performed on the kids show All That, Good Burger was an attempt to take one line
"Welcome to Good Burger home of the Good Burger,
can I take your order?"
And somehow turn that into an hour and a half movie. "Welcome to Good  Burger home of the Good Burger,
can I take your order?" No but you can take this, and shove it up hard!
The film Stars Kel Mitchell reprising his role as Ed, the idiot fast-food attendant who works at the
inappropriately titled Good Burger. It also stars Kenan Thompson, which is weird because he never really starred in any of the good burger sketches
But who the hell cares let's just get this ass burger review out of the way.
Alright, so it starts off with our protagonist, Ed. "Welcome to Good Burger, home of the Good Burger can I take your order?"
"Oh!"
Oh God
"Eeeed, I see youu"
What the fuck is that?
"I see you"
"I wanna stay here with you."
"We love you Ed."
"Come with us Ed".
"Fly Ed, fly"
"Weeee"
"Whoah, I'm flying with fast food!"
[Critic mouthing]
"I'm flying with hamburgers!"
[Screaming]
Agh! Welcome to Good Burger home of the Good Burger can I take-" Stop, stop. I need a minute.
[Whispers] Pull it together, pull it together!
So it turns out that opening was just a dream
But unfortunately the rest of the movie isn't,  as Ed rushes out the door because he's late to work
This is bad because nobody else at the restaurant knows how to take orders, which really pisses off huge, angry Robert Walls
"Just give me two Good Burgers! I had it up to here with Good Burger!"
Hey, I don't need this I had a cameo in Batman!
So we see Ed rushing down the street as he trips into some girls playing jump rope, drags one of them down the street,
accidentally steals a woman's baby, collides with some basketball players, mixes up the basketball with the baby as the baby is dumped into a basketball hoop
You know what I'm gonna need another minute.
[Sobs]
So Ed finally makes it to work only to find that there's another restaurant called
Mondo Burger being built across the street that could be dangerous competition
But their boss isn't worried. "Good Burger has been here for over 40 years and nobody is putting good burger out of business
[Chorus of "Yeahs"]
[Record stopping sound]
[Dialogue rewound]
Abe Vigoda what are you doing? Is there just really no movie that you'll say no to?
I mean, did you read the script? You know it couldn't have been a good movie!
My guess is he was in some sort of contract or something.
It probably went something like this.
[NC] "Abe, the president of Nickelodeon says you had to do the Good Burger movie."
"He can't do that. It screws up all my arrangements."
[NC]"Sorry Abe, you're under contract."
"Tom can you get me off the hook?
For old times sake."
[NC] Can't do it, Abe."
[NC] "Come on. You get to wear the little hat and everything."
So we then cut to our other main character Dexter, who's in a classroom being taught by- Oh Jesus no
[sigh] Being taught by Sinbad with an outfit made of wrapping paper and a haircut modeled after a blowfish.
His personality though? That's a little harder to figure out.
"I know you're thinking, my brother, WHY?
Why would this man give us a test on the last day of school before summer start, well I'm gon' tell you why because- [hits desk]
The mind never sleeps."
Right on my mid-seventies-early-eighties-black-panther-hippie-environmentalist-blacksploitation-flower-child...brother?
Dexter thinks he's out of school for the summer which means he can spend the rest of his time partying,
but there's a change of plan when he accidentally crashes into Ronald McDonald here.
"See when I left school today, I didn't think I was gonna run into you this summer, I didn't think you was gonna run into me!
I mean just right into me like this, you in trouble young man you in trouble with me!"
"No listen Mr. Weed(?) It wasn't my fault see this nut on some rollerblades.
He skated into my vision sight and I couldn't see nothin' so I swerved and I was spinnin' around-"
Okay, how long does this scene go?
"Do you know how much that car cost me?"
"No"
"Do you know?!"
"That's a $22,000 car. $22,000! And that's just the base price.
Give me your drivers license."
"Um, regarding my drivers license-"
Alright, seriously, did they just run out of script?
I mean it seems like they're just making this shit up now.
[Unfunny dialogue about Dexter not having a drivers license or insurance]
"Yes, I hate to do this young man. I hate to put a black man in jail. I'm gon' have to call the police."
"You ain't got to- I'm just a kid!"
It's like they knew they had no story a little jokes so they just told the actors to make some crap up off the top of their heads.
We have to fill that hour and a half movie somehow. What should I talk about? Who cares, it's just a kids film, it's not like you have to try.
My God, they're still going! This could be handled with just one line of dialogue." Oh shit, I need a job." Why is that so hard?
Finally a different scene- no no c'mon! How much longer do I have to see Raggedy Anne and that pincushion argue?!
Just get on with it! Get on with it! Oh wait no not that way, I didn't mean it like that just no no that's wrong that's wrong!
Bad touch! Bad touch, that's a very bad touch! Very bad no no stop it- alright I have no choice!
ELEPHANT!
[Angelic singing]
Oh, I never thought that would be my call back to reality, but I'll take it!
So Dexter has to get a summer job,
y'see, one sentence, that was so much easier. As he applies at the Mondo Burger where everyone dresses like they're at an eighties gym
"From now on
your life is
Mondo Burger.
You can forget about your friends, you can forget about your family,
because Kurt is now both your mother, and your father."
But Dexter, sadly doesn't seem to fit in.
"Get this loser out of my face!"
"Loser! Oh now you about to push me a little too far!" "You want a piece of me?"
"Yeah extra crispy, please!"
I hope Saturday Night Live ain't watching
So he goes to a place where his clear lack of talent and absolutely no experience will do him well
"But you said you wanted nothing on it"
"Yes, well I expected a meat patty!"  "Dude, a meat patty is something"
"You said nothing. Fizz, is a meat patty something or nothing?
Don't you get philosophical with me kid. It's not a kind of movie. [Imitating] We're all born to die sir.
So Ed and Dexter finally meet, as Dexter vents his "whoahs" (woes)
"One more Good Shake" "Good, good, keep 'em coming."
"Um, dude, don't you think you've had enough?"
[Slurring] Don't tell me when I've had enough Shakes, I'll tell you when I've had enough Shakes.[Crying] I'm sorry I didn't mean to snap at you
I'll chase it down with some fries.
So Ed tries to convince his boss that Dexter should begin the job at Good Burger
"Hey Mr. Bailey, this guy needs a job can he have one?" "No!" End of the movie bye
"C'mon Mr. Bailey he really needs one, he can do fries." "Otis does fries."
"Yeah, but look at him, how much longer could he possibly live?"
Nothing can kill me, I'm Abe Vigoda
"All right"
So Dexter is hired on as one of his jobs is to make deliveries in- I'm not kidding the burger mobile.
"Come on. I'll take you for a spin!"
[Batman theme and accompanying sound effects]
But all is not well as the ruler of Mondo Burger comes in to intimidate our heroes.
"The second we open our doors, good burger goes in the grinder"
What's up with this kid? It's like someone put Sting, Frankie Muniz and Ben Stiller in a blender, it's kind of surreal
"I'm Ed, huh."  "Well, Ed, you better watch your butt, man"
"Okay"
So mondo burger does open up to probably the most overblown Fast-food restaurant opening ever
Even planet Hollywood doesn't get this type of opening. I mean, what are they expecting to see in there?
Oh my God they have fries!
Honest-to-God fries!
So they take a look at one of the mondo burgers to see why their business is doing so well
"It's huge!"  "How do they do it?" My God they use actual meat, no raccoons at all
So Ed asks Dexter if he wants to hang out and-
"Do you think you get me to a hospital? I think I broke my ass."
Okay, yeah, I'm convinced now that Abe wasn't supposed to be in this movie
He just wandered onto the set threw on the costume and start walking around bumping into people. They were just like hey
He's not hurting anyone just keep them in the movie
You were in Godfather man show some dignity! As Ed and Dexter become more acquainted with each other it discovered that they have a
Complicated relationship. "I don't like you, can you get that through your head?". "Look, I'm grape nose boy!
Bloobity bloopity bloopity bloopity Bloobity bloopity bloopity bloopity
[This goes on for some time]
[NC yells shut up repeatedly]
[Insanity]
"Made you laugh!"  My God I just realized what this is, this is Dante's 11th level of hell
He just didn't write about cuz he thought it would be too scary for people to comprehend
[Voice over] And lo and behold an obnoxious douchebag with unconvincing dreads will
put grapes in his nose and constantly shout "bloopity bloopity bloopity bloopity" and it will be called the
11th level of Hell
Dante then wet himself and cried in fear. So turns out, Ed brings his own special sauce that
He made himself as people pass the round they realize it's pretty good
I personally don't trust anything that looks like a blended fraggle
But everyone else seems [to] as they marketed to the people raising their profits again
But dexter makes Ed sign a contract that lets dexter have 80% of all the money that they [make] on the sauce
Presumably high as a kite that agrees and continues to be shed upon by the people he thinks he knows and loves well
Here you go ed. You get to keep
$13 wow that's almost
$14, huh?
[wow], that is the stupidest thing
I've ever heard plain and simple but Edie being a sentimental guy ask dexter
If he wants to hang out on the rooftop and just look at the stars yeah apparently Ed's deep what kind of problems
Do you have?
Most of them sided when I was a little kid, that's when my dad [left] me and my mom
Must have lived in 15 places since then wait wait a minute. Are you actually trying to have a moment?
are you actually trying to emote an
emotion
other than disgust [I]
remember the last time I saw my dad I
Was seven years old [I'm] sorry. It's a little hard to get into this moment. Well one of the last scenes
We saw was I think I broke my ass that makes a little tricky [I]?
Give up. I'm going on
And I enact him I'm really going home fuck this movie
The next day they get a call to deliver a special order to the holy other celebrity they [could] afford in [this] movie
Feel hungry take the food take everybody
Just please don't do any rapid so the gift shake is order and even managed to get a little
Endorsement from him. Oh good. This is back in the days when is endorsements actually meant so order tomatoes on this good burger
I don't see no tomatoes well, [manga]
Consider yourself tomato. Huh? Wow, that's pretty badly and making Shaquille o'neal look like a good actor
Meanwhile [Mama] burger is just please the good burger sales are suddenly rising as it just steams their PVC spaces
Good burger is still in business
Well, what are we supposed [to] do about it our burgers are already twice the size of [an] [sceptic] may I recommend firing our photon
Torpedoes at the restaurant
kitchen, yes, sir
Make our burgers bigger bigger foot. They're already
but
There's still the problem as to how does [not] that special sauce and created so they decide [to] send in a beautiful woman to seduce
end and get his secret ingredients if anyone can get the sauce better pet
She can okay. [I] don't [wanna] know how she gets the sauce out of [idi]. I just assume. That's private oh
I felt that a while
So Roxanne tries to seduce Ed
But our attempts are [fetal] against a thick wall in this you are so hot oh
I often sweat it work. [huh] my God hallmark cards are funnier than this so you hungry
Yes, I am hungry
but not for food
I'm hungry for you. Oh
Well, well, I'm not edible
So it agrees to go out with Roxanna. [oh]
Hold up, well somebody give aid some direction back there
Give him a cookie or something [can] he come on [this] [ain't] A-Gonna. Not a dishrag. He's the funniest thing in this movie
[I] don't even think it's supposed to be there
So hank goes out with Roxanne [as] dexter also asked to have his coworker named monique
But I think he's doing that because he secretly wanted I mean look at them. They look exactly alike
I think that some closed doors here that need to be opened, [so] we roxanne tries to get intimate with N
But this turns out to be extraordinarily dangerous and she discovers that love hurts even more than she knows
Abuse to women is funny
After roxanne gives up at the hip love burglar and in dexter start to suspect foul play as they think Mondo burger is using illegal
Chemicals to make their food larger so they disguised themselves as on jesus really you're gonna go the drag route what?
What?
Why if I didn't know better? I'd say you were from a subpar childish sketch comedy show
After they [worked] their way inside our two heroes find out Mondo Burgers dirty little secret
people
No, it turns out that they were using illegal chemicals
But our heroes are caught as the head of mondo burger decides to do the first logical thing in this movie have them both committed
Finally it should have done at the beginning of them
So the [two-part] taken idiot interrupted as they try to figure out a way to [escape]
But while that's going on the mondo burger people partake admission implausible as they try to sabotage ed's sauce making everyone who eats it
incredibly sick
Let's go guy here guys you woke up abe
abe says he's gonna call the police, but the mondo burger decides to have him committed to I somehow doubt that was very hard
So our three nut jobs are stuck in a mental institution and have to figure a logical way out that solution
start a synchronized dance number! Of course, look at them go! You know, for the mentally disabled
they sure do have good on-the-fly dance choreography
I'm really impressed and as your sense of impossibility may have told you don't
Guards start dancing to [queue] up, let's go over here and dance
I think it's our job to stop out-of-control stuff like this
But pretty sure if we let our guard down once nothing bad can happen oh
So that's why we're not paying well okay, so they steal the keys get out of the room
But how are they going to get out of the actual building?  One of the local crazies decides to help them out.
You know for as bad as this movie is, I do like its sudden burst of cruelty
But how's a frail old man like a pagoda gonna get out of there , [and] that's the last we ever saw him
It's okay. I landed on the fat kid
they all tried to make it a good burger to stop the customers from getting sick as a suddenly turns out to be  the end of the
Benny Hill Show
(upbeat music playing)
Yeah, that's nice crashing the car breaks some teeth and endanger people's lives, but at least the good burger will stay open
But Ed and Dexter make it in time as Ed stops an old lady from eating one of the burgers. This needs to be censored
so Ed and Dexter explained about the sauce and stop all the orders just before they hatch a plan to break into Mondo Burger and
expose them for the liar's they are but first this joke.
I need a hot jakozzi
You know, what fuck it
So they figure out a plan to get into the mondo burger and get rid of all their chemicals
Gee I sure have a hungry for some rold gold pretzels right now. How do you expect me to get up there?
Oh, it's easy
You just jump on a burger jump on the fry and then you hop on a cup and then shimmy up the straw
What is this, American gladiators?
What is that, a joke?
so they break into the mondo burger and try to intimidate the rest of the cook
Mama never had one of these
with the electronic numbers we always had to turn the knob
If I was you, I wouldn't come any closer.
Stand back.. I think that's real ketchup.
OH NO, how are they gonna? Go around the restaurant covered in Ketchup and Mustard?
That's just silly
That's right. Smack your ass just show us what a likeable character you are. You little troublemaker?
Uh oh
How's Ed gonna screw it up this time?
*sensible chuckling*
Ed, you nincompoop, but I bet it'll all work out in the end somehow.. It always does
Uh Oh! It looks like all those chemicals are causing the burgers to explode!
That's so out of the ordinary. I dare call it wacky!  You people had better run faster
There's no telling what other zany antics could possibly follow
Ooo it's that character that nobody likes. (heavy sarcasm) Do you think he'll get his comeuppance in the end? Well, that all depends.
Do you want cheese on that?
Oh ho ho
It looks like God is finally smoting you for making jingle all the way, sinbad.
Good luck trying to clean that up
What a mess!
Well, it looks like our two lovable skanks and finally come out on top
They were scary moments at times, but was there ever any doubt that
They'd make it in the end.  I don't think so.  So, after *all* this wild crazy and totally off-the-wall antics
How else can they possibly end this movie besides saying the classic line?
Welcome to good burger home of the good burger. Can I take your order?
You certainly can ed. You certainly can
DIIIIIIIIEEEE!
This is crap. It's got awful good burger?  Good God! What a lot of shit
it's like if shit could shit and that shit could shit and that shit could shit and that shit to raise money to put together a
Team of Filmmakers directors of steaming flaming pile of shit.  you forever
My advice is leave this order a monkey puke forever
And never look back as long as you live or even after you die
because that way at least God knows you're trying to do better. I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to
About this contract man ... What do you say we just forget it.
You don't want to be partners?
Well, no. See....
Is it because I'm black?
AHH, a funny joke!